.
S..
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
THE NON EXCITING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ISSUES TODAY.
CARE TO A.
IN A PAIR OF SORRY IS THE TRUTH.
APPEAR TO US TO YESTERDAY. BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE DON'T SELL
A LOT OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
YEAH THE WORKFORCE OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION.
SEGMENT IN OUR COUNTRY AND.
A FEW IMPORTANT ISSUES TO
DISCUSS TODAY.
.
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
OUR COLLEGE UPROMISE LE FUNDING.
PROGRAM FOCUSED ON X. INCREASING
ACCESS TO COMMUNICABLE SIX WEEK
LOTS LAST YEAR THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS AND PLEASE AT THE.
GOVERNOR SIGNED THE BILL THE IN
THE YEAR.
AS WELL AS OF A FEW OTHER.
ISSUES WITH DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
INNOVATION AWARDS STAFFING AND
THE VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER.
SO WITH THAT LET'S START WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
PROP FIFTY ONE CAPITAL OUTLAY.
LOW.
I'M MANY CATS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THANK
YOU OF SOMETHING MEMBER MCCARTY
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSAL.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
FIFTY NINE POINT TWO MILLION IN
GEO BOND AUTHORITY FOR SIXTEEN
CONTINUING AND FIVE NEW
PROJECTS.
THAT ADDRESS CRITICAL FIRE LIFE
SAFETY ISSUE STATEWIDE.
ALL BUT ONE PROJECT WILL BE
FUNDED FROM THE PROP FIFTY ONE
ON SO RECENTLY PASSED.
OVER ALL THESE PROJECTS WOULD
OBLIGATE APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED MILLION OF THE TWO
BILLION AND PROPOSITION FIFTY
ONE BONDS PROVIDED FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THERE'S SOME DISCUSSION HERE ON
THE ADMINISTRATION. SO THEY JUST
GO INTO THAT THE.
DIMINISH CITIZENS RATIONALE FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
ACROSS ALL DEPARTMENTS STATE
WHY NOT JUST COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IS THAT FUNDS FOR NEW PROJECTS
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO ISSUES.
SUCH AS FIRE LIFE SAFETY OR
COURT MANDATES.
BUT WE WOULD NOTE THAT VIOLATES
SAFETY DOES NOT NEED TO BE THE
SOLE CRITERION FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROJECTS. TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR FUNDING. BUT I
SHOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT DRIVER.
IN ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERS WHETHER REQUESTING
DISTRICT AND PROVIDE SOME LEVEL
OF MATCH
WHETHER THERE ARE EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT PREVENTED
DISTRICT KIDDING.
AN EXAMPLE OF THE LATTER WOULD
INCLUDE.
READ WHAT'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT THAT'S A. SMALL
DISTRICT THAT HAS SOME
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
RESULTING FROM A RECENT SEISMIC
ANALYSES.
I CONSISTENT WITH THE POLICY THE
ADMINISTRATION LEVEL EXPECTS
WILL BE LOCAL MATCHING FUNDS AS
PART OF THE FUTURE REQUESTS FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION PAYS A THREE
CONTINUING PROJECTS.
TWO IN SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND ONE IN
PASADENA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
OF THE FIVE YEAR PLAN NOTES THAT
THE COMMITTEE CALLED SO
CALIFORNIA FIGHTER PLANET NOTES
THAT THE COMMUNICABLE EDGES. OF
REPORTED OVER TWENTY BILLION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS.
WITH ONLY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
REMAINING AND PROP FIFTY ONE.
OF WE BELIEVE THAT STATE
INVESTMENT SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
THOSE PROJECTS THAT ADDRESS THE
CRITICAL FIRE LIFE SAFETY NEEDS.
AND WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU LA JOH.
GOOD AFTERNOON A GROUP BROUGHT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND WE DON'T OF ANY PARTICULAR
CONCERNS WITH THE PROJECT EVER
CHOSE THEM.
BY THE ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. I'M ARE
OUR MAIN CONCERN IS THAT THE THE
GOVERNOR FUNDS TO FEW PROJECTS
I'M CONSIDERING THAT THE SIZE OF
THE PROP FIFTY ONE BOND WHICH
WAS TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE PROJECTS INCLUDED IN THE
IN THE BUDGET.
AT UP TO ABOUT SEVEN PERCENT OF
THE A COMMITTEE BECAUSE PROP
FIFTY ONE I'M FUNDING SO WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER AUTHORIZING. A MORE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROJECTS AND
DEVELOPING A MULTI YEAR PLAN FOR
SPENDING THOSE AND WE THINK THAT
WOULD. HELP OUR CREE CERTAINLY
FOR THE COLLEGES AND ENSURE THAT
THE VOTER APPROVED BONDS ARE
SPENT.
IN A TIMELY MANNER AND WE WE
HAVE BEEN REVIEWED THEIR YOUR
AGENDA INCLUDES. THE NINE
PROJECTS THAT THAT ARE THE
CHANCES OF WAS APPROVED THAT
WE'RE NOT.
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET WE DON'T
WE DON'T REVIEW ALL THOSE TELL
YOU WHICH ONES YOU THINK ARE THE
THE ONES THAT YOU SHOULD.
UNFUNDED WE DO THINK THAT THAT
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE WE SHOULD CONSIDER
ADDING ADDITIONAL ONES
OKAY.
LET ME ASK YOU JUST A QUESTION
RIGHT THERE SO CERTAINLY WE SEE
THE LIST ON ON THE STAFF REPORT.
AND.
YOU KNOW THEY ALL SEEM LIKE
WITHOUT PROJECTS ANOTHER MANY
OTHERS I'M JUST CONFUSED HOW
COULD WE APPROVE THEM.
IF THE BONDS HAVE TO BE.
SOLD BY THE GOVERNOR SO HOW
DOES THAT HELP IF WE APPROVE IT
BUT THE.
COVER DOES NOT TAKE THE FINAL
ACTION.
BECAUSE I GET TO. RIDE THE GOD
IS ONE OF THE TOWNS DIDN'T NOT
NONE OF THIS CAN HAPPEN
COMPLETELY YET UNILATERALLY I
THINK THERE IS. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CABIN IN THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATE.
BOND FUNDS FIVE FOR THIS
PURPOSE BUT IT DOES REQUIRE THEN
THE ADMINISTRATION YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THAT TURNED TO SELL THESE
BONDS SO THERE DOES NEED TO BE
SOME COORDINATION. INVOLVED ARM
IN AND AND I THINK IF I'M THAT
THAT WOULD BE A PART OF THE THE
THE TIME THAT WE DO THINK THAT
IF YOU YOU DO ADD. BUT THE BILL
LANGUAGE OR OTHER LANGUAGE THAT
MAKES VERY CLEAR YOUR INTENT BUT
THROUGH.
COULD BE GREENER.
CERTAINTY THAT THESE PROJECTS
WOULD BE ULTIMATELY APPROVED
UNFUNDED I'M TO THE PROCESS.
YEAH I'M SO IF I CAN JUST ADD ON
THAT
SO WHILE THE PROJECTS LISTED
JUST DON'T DON'T.
.
DON'T REALLY FIT WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CRITERIA OR
ULTIMATELY THAT FALL WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S ABILITY TO SUSTAIN OR
VETO PROJECT. AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE SUSTAINED WE WOULD
EXPECT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PROJECTS AND THEN AS NECESSARY
SO THOSE BONDS. OKAY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PERFECT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR CHRISTIAN OSPINA
WITH THAT COMPANY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. UP
WE APPRECIATE THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT NEARED AGENDA OF
OUR REVIEW AND APPROVAL PROCESS
ON BEHALF OF BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
IN THE IMMEDIATE TERM I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY AS SECURING FUNDING FOR
THE PROP PROJECTS WERE PUT INTO
THE IN THE SYSTEMS BUDGET
REQUEST.
AS OUR AGENDA NOTES I AM
PREPARING ARE SOME MIDDLE FOR
ADOPTION BY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WE FOCUSED ON PROJECTS THAT WERE
UNFUNDED AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
SO THOSE REPRESENT OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES OF THE PROJECTS IN
THE QUEUE. OUR PROPOSAL INCLUDES
THIRTY PROJECTS FIFTEEN
CONTINUING PROJECTS AND FIFTEEN
NEW PROJECTS BUT ONE WAS
WITHDRAWN RECENTLY. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FUNDS ONLY
FIVE OF THEM SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION A
JUSTIFIABLE WE HOPE SOME
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS ARE INCLUDED
IN THEIR SPRING PROPOSALS.
BUT ARE ASKING THIS BUDGET
PROCESS IS THAT YOU APPROVE THE
REMAINING PROJECTS NOT REQUEST.
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE TO
REITERATE THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEED IN OUR
SYSTEM.
OUR FIVE YEAR PLAN WHICH WAS
ADOPTED BY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS LAST FALL PROJECTS IN
NEED OF TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS
OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD. FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
OF THAT ABOUT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IS FOR CONSTRUCTION OF
NEW FACILITIES ABOUT TWELVE
BILLION IS FOR MODERNIZATION OF
EXISTING FILLED FACILITIES. OVER
TEN YEARS WE ESTIMATE THAT NEED
GROWS TO ABOUT FORTY TWO
BILLION.
AND SO AS YOU KNOW MEETING
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S BEEN
SHARED BY THE STATE IN THE
DISTRICTS. AND WE ACCOUNT FOR
THAT WE ASSUME THAT ABOUT FORTY
PERCENT OF THE NEED IS ADDRESS
WITH LOCAL FUNDS. AND ACCOUNTING
FOR.
LOCAL FUNDS AND PROP FIFTY ONE
BOND FUNDS WE ESTIMATE IN OUR
PLAN THAT WE'D NEED ABOUT
SEVENTEEN BILLION IN ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDS OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS.
SO AS I DISCUSSED IN A PREVIOUS
HEARING OVER THE LONGER TERM WE
THINK A DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW TO
BEST MEET THOSE NEEDS MAKE
SENSE.
YOU KNOW CHANCELLOR OAKLEY'S
BEEN WILLING TO REFORM EXISTING
PRACTICES IN OTHER AREAS TO MEET
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS. AND WE.
WE HOPE TO WORK WITH YOU IN
THIS AREA TO SEVER WE THINK THIS
IS A SHORT TERM CONVERSATION IN
THE BUDGET ABOUT GETTING THE
PROJECTS FUNDED BUT WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE A LONG TERM CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO MEET.
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS FOR
APOLOGIES.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MEMBERS THE ONE THAT
SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE FROM THE
PUBLIC.
WELL.
THANK YOU I CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD WITHOUT MCCALLUM GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS RIOS SAN
DIEGO. NOT SENTENCING TO ON YUBA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
I THINK YOUR ANALYSIS DOES A
VERY GOOD JOB OF LAYING OUT THE
ISSUE. THE.
BOARD OF GOVERNORS HAS A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS THAT SELECTS
THE PROJECTS AND HAS KNOWN TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND SO WE SUPPORT
THAT PROCESS AND WOULD SUPPORT
YOU APPROVING ALL OF THESE
PROJECTS ONCE AGAIN AS HE DID
LAST YEAR THANK YOU.
IS THE CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PABLO MONS ASSOCIATE VICE
CHANCELLOR FACILITIES MANAGEMENT
FOR THE LOS RIOS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT I'M HERE TO
URGE YOU TO FUND ALL FOURTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AT CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS RECOMMENDED BY
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THIS WOULD INCLUDE FUNDING OUR
NATOMA CENTER PROJECT. IS
LOCATED ADJACENT TO ENTER COME
HIGH SCHOOL. OF SO THE ADDITION
OF CLASSES AND SERVICES OFFERED
IS A RESULT OF THE PROJECT'S
COMPLETION WOULD ALLOW THE
COLLEGE TO EXPAND SUCCESSFUL
COLLABORATION WITH THE HIGH
SCHOOL THAT PROVIDES A PATHWAY
TO COLLEGE WIENER COME STUDENTS.
AS WELL AS WORKING ADULTS THE
NATOMA CENTERS IS POSITION TO
LEAD OUR DISTRICT AND EFFORTS IN
INTEGRATING DUAL ENROLLMENT
GUIDED PATHWAYS COLLEGE PROMISED
AN INNOVATIVE NEW APPROACHES TO
OUR PARTNERSHIP. THEREFORE THE
CENTER'S UNIQUE RELATIONSHIP A
NEIGHBOR INCOME HIGH SCHOOL
COMBINED WITH ITS TRACK RECORD
IT INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO
FACILITATING STUDENT SUCCESS.
MAKE THIS THE IDEAL NEW
FACILITY.
AN IDEAL LOCATION TO INTEGRATE
THESE IMPORTANT STATE REFORM
INITIATIVES SO WE ASK THAT YOU
HONOR THE WILL OF THE VOTERS AND
FUND ALL FOURTEEN OF THESE
PROJECTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY COALITION WE ARE ALSO
URGING YOU TO FUND ALL FOURTEEN
OF THE NEW CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS IN THE EIGHTEENTH
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR. AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WHEN VOTERS APPROVED
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE THAT THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT THEY
AUTHORIZED FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WAS FOR CONSTRUCTION.
RENOVATION RECONSTRUCTION AND
THE EQUIPPING OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACILITIES SO AS YOU CAN
SEE THAT'S MUCH BROADER THAN
JUST THE NARROW HEALTH AND
SAFETY LANDS THAT FINANCES
USING.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ALWAYS
PRIORITIZES HEALTH AND SAFETY
FIRST THOUGHTS THAT FIRST
CATEGORY THAT THEY FIND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT YOU WOULD BE
HONORING THE WILL OF THE VOTERS
BY APPROVING ALL FOURTEEN
PROJECTS WE THINK THAT THE COSTS
OF DELAY. OUTWEIGH ANY POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF WEEDING INCREASING
INTEREST RATES CONSTRUCTION
COSTS WALL DECREASE YOUR
PURCHASING POWER AND YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO I'M A ESSENTIALLY FUND
FEWER PROJECTS WITH YOUR TWO
BILLION DOLLARS TO LONGER THAT
YOU MIGHT. THINK YOU.
SIMPLICITY ON BEHALF OF FACULTY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ENERGY TO OUT FULLY
FUNDED THE FOURTEEN PROJECTS
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER BAKER AT
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO REPRESENTING
THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
MOVING THESE PROJECTS FOR WORD
WE CONCUR THAT WE NEED TO SEE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FROM PROP FIFTY
FOUR FIFTY ONE RELEASE AND WE
THINK THAT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDED. WITHIN STOP AND ON THE
LA EL IN THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ADEQUATELY REFLECTED DIRECTION
OF THE VOTERS THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON LIZETTE EVER WITH THE
CAMINO COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE ALIGN MY.
POINTS WITH A LOT OF THOSE THAT
ALREADY MENTIONED IF YOU WANT TO
ADD TO THAT OVERALL THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ANTICIPATE TO
A TWENTY NINE POINT NINE BILLION
IN FACILITIES NEEDS.
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR A SMALL
PORTION OF THOSE AND AGREED THAT
I'M OUR COLLEGES ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INCREASING
COSTS OF CONSTRUCTION THE LONGER
WE WAIT FOR THESE PROJECTS TO BE
RELEASE OF THANK YOU. AGAIN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
LAST YEAR.
OKAY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MR MESSAGE.
AND EIGHT RESPONSE SITE I THINK
I KNOW YOUR ANSWER BETTER.
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE CONSERVE
ONLY GONNA GET HIGHER.
YEAH I MEAN.
THANK THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
AND AND WHILE WE DO REALIZE
THERE IS.
THAT THERE IS INFLATION OVER
TIME OF OUR PRIORITIES IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MOST CRITICAL
PROJECTS.
SO WE'RE AT THIS TIME ONLY ABLE
TO SUPPORT THOSE UNDER FIRE LIFE
SAFETY.
SURE AND I I GUESS THAT MAY BE A
FOLLOW UP. TO THAT IS THAT.
YEAH THAT THAT MEASURE PASS
IN THE BONDS HAVE BEEN ISSUED SO
THERE'S JUST THIS.
GAP THAT'S JUST WAITING AND SO
THIS IS THAT LAST YEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S TERM SO. IS IT IS
YOUR INDICATION THAT FUTURE
GOVERNORS WOULD FOLLOW THE SAME
DESIRE WITH THEY.
YOU KNOW OR DID YOU THINK THAT.
FINANCE WOULD HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE.
I I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE DIRECTION
OF FUTURE GOVERNOR SARAH BUT IS
IT THE GOVERNOR'S DESIRE TO TO
JUSTIFY AND. LIFE AND SAFETY
PROJECTS AND AND NOTHING ELSE
AND JUST.
BUT TO THE NEXT UP THROUGH THE
NEXT ROUND BECAUSE THAT THE.
CAPACITY FOR.
THE STATE TO ISSUE THE BONDS
PASTOR REMAINS.
WHAT CHANGES A YEAR FROM NOW?
YEAH AGAIN.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE DIRECTION
THAT THE PROVIDED BY FUTURE
GOVERNOR.
AND IN DEFEAT IT BUT I I DO
THINK WAS IT AS A GOOD POINT AS
COSTS GO UP BUT.
NOW INTEREST RATES GO UP AND THE
FED RAISED INTEREST RATES THIS
MORNING.
SO IF YOU WERE GOING TO DO THESE
PROJECTS
EVENTUALLY IT WOULD MAKE SENSE
TO YOU WANNA DO THEM NOW WHEN
IT'S.
WHEN IT'S CHEAPER TO ASK TO
BORROW MONEY RIGHT.
UP POTENTIALLY ON THERE COULD BE
SOME CONCERNS ON HOW SHARP SPIKE
AND THEN BONDS COULD BE VIEWED.
BASED ON.
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL CAP FOR A
GIVEN A GEO BOND SALE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU YOU DOING YOUR JOB
YOU'RE DOING WELL.
I.
OKAY WELL WE WE RESPECTFULLY I
DISAGREE AND WE KNOW THAT WE CAN
PUSH.
SOME THESE PROJECTS FOR WOULD
JUST ME WE DO SO BUT REALIZE IN
THE DAY. IT'S ON IT'S THE THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THEIR AND THEIR ROLE AS FAR
AS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO IN THIS IS
THAT.
NOW LET'S TAKE THEIR OFFERS.
MCCARTY HERE.
OBERNOLTE.
MURATSUCHI.
VOEPEL.
OKAY THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER TWO
THAT THAT CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE FUNDING IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE REALLY.
INTRIGUED ABOUT TO PUSH LAST
YEAR AND WAS.
PLEASE A THAT WAS IN IN THE
FINAL.
BUDGET ACTION BUT WE WERE ABLE
TO TACKLE IT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS LATER IN THE
YEAR. SO WITH WITH THIS IS THE
FIRST YEAR IMPLEMENTATION THAT.
AND.
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
TO WANTED TO GIVE THAT PERMIT A
FINANCING THE COMMITTEE CALLED
AS AN OPPORTUNITY. TO TALK ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION.
STARTING WITH THIS YEAR SO
LET'S START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
I HAVE READ SO HE SAT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FORTY SIX MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
NINETEEN AND CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE CONSISTENT WITH AB
NINETEEN COLLEGES COULD USE THIS
FUNDING TO WAIT SOME. OR ALL OF
THE FORTY SIX DOLLAR PER UNIT
FEE FOR ALL FIRST TIME I
RESIDENTS STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
AT TWELVE UNITS OR MORE PER
SEMESTER DURING THE FIRST YEAR.
AND TO SUPPORT PROMISE SEEN OUR
PRACTICES TO ADVANCE AS SPECIFY
STUDENT SUCCESS SCHOOLS. WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WHILE THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
CURRENTLY DEFINES FULL TIME*
OF.
CREDIT UNITS UP PURSE MASTER.
STUDENT CREATED THIRTY UNITS
THIRTY PROGRAM APPLICABLE UNITS
PER YEAR TO GRADUATE IN TWO
YEARS SO THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPECTS THAT ONCE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES IMPLEMENT GUIDED
PATHWAYS. AT THAT ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS TO TAKE.
FIFTEEN UNITS PER SEMESTER
THIRTY I UNITS PER YEAR I'VE TO
FURTHER ENCOURAGE THAT TIMELY
COMPLETION.
THINK UN HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
AND WHAT ABOUT WHAT THE LA WHAT
WE DID HAVE ANY A PARTICULAR
CONCERNS HERE WITHOUT THE
ESTIMATES ARE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET REASONABLE AND ARE IN
LINE WITH THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION.
AND CHRISTIAN ALSO UNDER THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HOLDERS
TALKED BRIEFLY ABOUT METHODOLOGY
WHILE WE'RE STILL FINALIZING OUR
APPROACH.
BUT OUR PLAN IS TO DISTRIBUTE
FUNDSTO COLLEGES BASED ON THEIR
COUNTS OF FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT ALREADY
COVERED BY THE FEE WAIVER.
IN THE YEAR FOR WHICH FUNDS ARE
BUDGETED SO FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WE DISTRIBUTE FUNDS
USING TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
COUNTS.
OUGHT TO DO SO WILL NEED A
MECHANISM TO ADJUST OUR
APPORTIONMENT SPIT LE AS THOSE
NUMBERS.
HAVE BECOME FINALIZED OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR OF THE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE THEIR
PROPRIOCEPTIVE.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ALLOWS IS FOR US TO DO THAT
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT OTHER
MECHANISMS AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU AUTHOR WITH A FEW
SO CERTAINLY.
AGAIN.
VERY PLEASED BY THIS I THINK
IT'S A. GAME CHANGER MAKING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
FREE ON TO THE TO THE MASSES IN
GRAD STUDENTS COULD GO GET THE.
FORMALLY BOB WEAVER BUT THE
YEARS I THINK THIS
THE GREAT.
MARKETING OPPORTUNITY TALK
ABOUT COLLEGE PEOPLE WHO. MAYBE
NECESSARILY WERE SITTING ON THE
SIDELINES WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY IN ONLINE DISCUSS WE
NEED TO GET.
STRANDED POPULATION AS FAR AS
HIGHER EDUCATION BACK IN THE
GAME IN A ROLLING IN THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I THINK THIS
HAS. A TREMENDOUS.
UPSIDE AND I DID WANT TO ASK
ABOUT THE.
THE ACTIVITIES THAT THAT WERE
LAID OUT IN THAT LEGISLATION OF
COURSE SO.
I HAVE HAD HOW. HOW DO YOU
FOLLOW UP TO MAKE SURE THAT?
THE COLLEGE
AND COMPLETED THE ACTIVITIES
AS FAR AS ELSA BELIEVES IN THAT
KIND OF THINK THAT NUMBER ONE
THE NUMBER TWO. IS IT PER THE
COLLEGE.
DISTRICT OR THE ACTUAL
INDIVIDUAL COLLEGE.
.
THE OUR INTENT RIGHT NOW WE'VE
BEEN AYE TRACKING ON A COLLEGE
BASIS.
AND SO COLLEGES I THINK THE TWO
THAT ARE.
HAVE BEEN.
OF PRIMARY CONCERN HAVE BEEN
AROUND THE PARTICIPATION IN THE
FEDERAL LOAN PROGRAM.
AS A HAVE THE UPDATE I RECEIVE
TODAY THINK RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
TWENTY TWO COLLEGES I CAN SYSTEM
OF YOUR AGENDA THAT.
JIM DON'T CURRENTLY PARTICIPATE
IN THE LOAN PROGRAM I THINK MOST
OF THOSE ARE EXPLORING
PARTICIPATION BUT WILL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THAT AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO PROVIDE YOU. WITH UPDATED
INFORMATION IS THAT MOVES
FORWARD.
THE OTHER ONE THAT IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO US IS
PARTICIPATION IN THE GUIDED
PATHWAYS STRUCTURE THE FRAY OFF
FOLLOWING THAT FRAMEWORK. OF AT
THIS POINT MOST CALL IT ALL
COLLEGES HAVE INDICATED THAT
THEIR.
GOING DOWN THAT PATH I THINK
THE EXPECTATIONS WILL CONTINUE
TO GROW MOVING FORWARD AND SO
WILL WE'RE GONNA BE MONITORING
THAT BUT I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS THAT. AS
WE BUILD AND.
YOU KNOW COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS WE WANT TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS WHO ENTER.
ON A PATHWAY TO SUCCESS SO. I
THINK WE WE SEE THAT IS CRITICAL
TO THE PROGRAM WE THINK WE'RE
ON.
GOING DOWN THE RIGHT PATH WE'RE
GONNA MONITOR THAT.
SO THE ONLY THAT ACTIVITY THAT
MAYBE QUESTION RIGHT NOW ARE
THESE COLLEGES THAT THAT HAVE
NOT PARTICIPATED WITH THAT.
FEDERAL LOAN THAT'S CORRECT AND
JUST JUST MAYBE COULDN'T HELP US
WHY WOULD A COLLEGE.
NOT HAVE BEEN DOING THIS ALL
THESE YEARS.
THIS IS ANECDOTAL AND CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW HAVEN'T TALKED BROADLY
ENOUGH I THINK.
ONE IS KIND OF.
BELIEFS ABOUT LOANS AND AND I
THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME CONCERN
ABOUT.
LOAN PRACTICES AND WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT I THINK THE OTHER.
IS ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S TIED
TO PRODUCE MISSION IN THE
FEDERAL LOAN PROGRAMS AND NOT.
.
NOT WANTING SAID TO TAKE ON.
THAT HAVE A POPULATION OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE TAKING A LOANS
WHERE.
COHORT DEFAULT RATES ARE USED
AS A MEASURE OF INSTITUTIONAL
SUCCESS I THINK THE THIRD PART
IS ALSO JUST THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OF.
SPENDING THE LOAN PROGRAM.
LOANS ARE AREN'T ALWAYS PROUD
LED THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE AS
MUCH AS
YOU SEE THIS IS HERE PRAISE
APPLE IT JUST WASN'T A PRIORITY.
BUT AND AND I THINK THE I THINK
THE BE BIGGER ISSUE IS PROBABLY
THAT IT CREATES BURDENS BOTH ON.
THE CAN OF A WORKLOAD STAFFING
BURDEN BUT ALSO IN A.
A CONCERN THAT INSTITUTIONS WHO
HAVE HIGH COHORT DEFAULT RATES.
.
LIKE.
THERE ARE PUT POLICIES TIED TO
TO THAT MEASURE AND SO WE COULD.
GET THEM IN TROUBLE FOR THE
PURPOSES
OKAY.
QUESTIONS FOR MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HOW DO
WE.
YEAH MISS WALDRON.
SO I WAS INTERESTED TO READ IN
THE LA NEWS ANALYSIS OF THIS
THEIR THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
PERENNIAL TENSION BETWEEN.
WANTING TO GRAB MORE STUDENTS
ACCESS TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ON THE ONE HAND BUT ALSO NEEDING
TO ENSURE STUDENT SUCCESS ON THE
OTHER HAND BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
DOES US NO GOOD AS A SOCIETY. TO
HAVE MORE PEOPLE COME IN NOW IF
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN WHAT THEY'RE
ENDEAVORING TO ACHIEVE SO I AND
WHAT AS YOU KNOW WE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITHOUT OF THE
LIGHTED LATEST STATISTICS I
READ.
SAY THAT FOR ONLY FORTY PERCENT
AND PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS THAT
COME IN EITHER.
ACHIEVE A TWO YEAR DEGREE.
IN AN EDUCATIONAL CERTIFICATE
OR TRANSFER OUT TO HAVE HIGHER.
INSTITUTION WITHIN SIX YEARS SO
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S. REALLY A
RED FLAG IN MY MIND AND SO FAR.
I'M WONDERING HOW DO YOU ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A LARGE NEW INFLUX
IN FIRST YEAR STUDENTS TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
IF I HAVEN'T MENTIONED IT YET I
THINK THIS IS KIND OF YOU KNOW.
THEIR VISION FOR SEX SUCCESS
BECOMES KIND OF OUR HAS BEEN
OUR.
TENTATIVE YOU KNOW NORTH STAR
OVER THE PASSING OF SINCE IT WAS
ADOPTED LAST YEAR I THINK THAT'S
YOU KNOW I. I THINK WE WOULD SAY
WE DON'T SEE THESE TWO
PRIORITIES AS INTENTION THAT I
THINK.
ACCESS IS IMPORTANT IT'S
HISTORICALLY BEEN IMPORTANT AS
IMPORTANT AS PART OF A MASTER
PLAN.
BUT THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE AND WE
HAVE.
THERE WE HAVE MADE OUR CORE.
OUT MISSION OVER THE NEXT COMING
YEARS IN THIS CHANCELLOR HAS
MADE HIS CORE MISSION TO ADDRESS
THESE. CHALLENGES OF STUDENT
SUCCESS THAT IT'S YOU KNOW OUR
VISION FOR SUCCESS SCHOOLS ORDER
INCREASE TRANSFERRING COMPLETE
DIED INCREASED COMPLETIONS DE
PEOPLE INTO THE WORKFORCE AND.
AREAS THAT ARE.
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR PROGRAM
OF STUDY AND CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS BOTH.
ACROSS A STUDENT.
RACIAL ETHNIC GROUPS BUT ACROSS
ALSO.
REGION SO I THINK THIS IS KIND
OF A CENTRAL PART OF THIS GUIDED
PATHWAYS IS THE WAY IN WHICH WE
HAVE.
YOU KNOW STRUCTURED OUR SYSTEM
TO DEATH THERE THAT ARE YOU KNOW
GUIDED PATHWAYS IS THAT IT'S AN
ATTEMPT TO MOVE FROM.
THE KIND OF AYE CAFETERIA STYLE
MODEL OF OF EDUCATIONAL
DELIVERY.
TO ONE THAT IS FOCUSED ON
IDENTIFYING WITH THE STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL GOAL IS UPON ENTRY.
CREATING A PATHWAY FOR THEM TO
GET THEIR PROVIDING THE SPORTS
THING NEED TO DO THAT SO THAT SO
I WOULD SAY THIS IS OUR THAT IS
OUR CENTRAL MISSION I THINK
GETTING MORE FOLKS THROUGH THE
DOORS IS IMPORTANT BUT WE.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
THEY GET OUT WITH A WITH A DOT
COM.
BUT THE DEGREE CREDENTIAL
TRANSFER.
WHATEVER THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOAL
WAS.
WELL I MEAN WE'RE ON THE SAME
TEAM OBVIOUSLY WE ALL WANT THE
SAME THING WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
ACCESSIBILITY TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM ON THE ONE HAND.
AND THE MAXIMUM SUCCESS FOR
STUDENTS ON THE OTHER BUT.
I HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH YOU THAT THIS IS NOT THIS
INFLUX OF NEW STUDENTS IS NOT
GOING TO AFFECT OUR SUCCESS RATE
IN FACT. IF YOU WANT MY
PREDICTION I THINK THAT THAT
READ THE FORTY SEVEN PERCENT
RATE THAT I JUST COULD I THINK
THAT'S GONNA GO DOWN. AS A
RESULT OF THIS INITIATIVE AND I
THINK IF WE'RE NOT CAREFUL. THAT
IT'LL GO DOWN SUBSTANTIALLY SO I
I MYSELF AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
MAKING SURE. THAT WE DON'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THE THE OVERALL
OBJECTIVE HERE WHICH IS NOT TO
HAVE A BUNCH A PEOPLE GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT TO HAVE
THEM BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND THAT'S WOMAN WHEN YOU'RE
GAUGING THE OVERALL HEALTH OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE SOCIETY
SOCIETAL BENEFIT THAT WERE
ACHIEVING. THAT SHOULD BE THE
METRIC THAT WERE FOCUSED ON NOT
NUMB THE NUMBER FOR STUDENTS TO
COME IN BUT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO WHO LEAVE
SUCCESSFULLY.
AND IT ALL AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT I THINK THAT THAT'S THE
METRIC WE OUGHT BE LOOKING AT.
SO IT A FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO
THE OHIO. ON THE THE NEW FUNDING
FORMULA DOES THIS HELP ADDRESS
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE LINK
BETWEEN THOSE TWO NUMBERS.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE THE FUNDING
FOR MEDICAL WE THINK THAT IS A
WAY TO HELP ENSURE THAT
REGARDLESS WITH HAPPENING ON THE
IN ROOM INSIDE. KNOW WHETHER
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY STUDENTS
ARE COMING AND WHETHER THEY'RE
COMING IN BECAUSE OF VERY
RECEIVE A FEW WAIVER OR.
YOU KNOW UNDER EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WOULD NOW RECEIVE THE
WAIVER THAT WE DO HAVE A
INSTANCES FOR COLLEGES TO REALLY
FOCUS ON OUTCOMES SO. I THINK
I'M.
WE DON'T THINK THAT YOU HAVE TO
CHOOSE ONE OR THE OTHER WE WE
THINK IF YOU DO HAVE A FUNDING
FOR MY THAT'S MORE ALIGNED. TO.
YEAH AND FOCUSED ON HOW STUDENT
SUCCESS THEN YOU CAN.
IS SURE THAT COLLEGES ARE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT AND I
THINK THE REQUIREMENT OF GUIDED
PATHWAYS WITHIN THE MISSIVE IT
WITH THAT MAYBE NINETEEN ALSO.
HELPED WITH THAT THEY CUT THE
COLLEGES QUIRK WHO AGREED TO
TAKE THE FUNDING IN AND ALLOW
OTHER STUDENTS TO COMMIT ARE
ALSO AGREEING. TO DO TO
IMPLEMENT GUIDED PATHWAYS TO TRY
TO HELP SUPPORT SOON SO WHEN
THEY COME IN THEY HAVE BETTER
DIRECTION IN TERMS OF WHAT THEIR
EDUCATION PLANS AND HOW THEY
WANT TO. ABOUT WHAT THEIR GOALS
ARE SUBJECT BE COULD HELP
SUPPORT THE MISSION THAT THE
COMPLETE.
ALRIGHT WELL I HOPE YOU'RE
RIGHT.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT OVERALL
IF WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
ACHIEVES A HIGHER NUMBER OF
STUDENTS. THAT ARE SUCCESSFULLY
GETTING THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THEN WE ALL WENT.
BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE FOCUSED ON THAT OBJECTIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU ANY.
YEAH PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD MCCALLUM GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE A NUMBER OF LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
INCLUDING LAS RIOS.
SAN DIEGO SAN FRANCISCO ONE OF
FIRST DIVE THANK THE CHAIR IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
REGARDING THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR.
WE THINK THAT THIS IS A GREAT
PROPOSAL AND WOULD URGE YOU TO
FIND THAT WE ALSO SUPPORT. THE
METHODOLOGY THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS USING TO
DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDS WE THINK
THAT THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO DO
IT. MISTER OBERNOLTE TO ADDRESS
YOUR CONCERNS AT THE END OF.
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION LAST
YEAR.
THERE WAS NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
STATE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
IMPLEMENT STUDENT SUCCESS
PURPOSE PROCEDURES IN ORDER FOR
THE COLLEGES TO RECEIVE THESE
FUNDS AND THOSE ARE INCLUDED IN
AB NINETEEN. WHICH WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED HERE.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ALL HUDDLED AROUND
WHAT THE WYOMING GROUP
REPRESENTING NEXT AND CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN M.
WERE VERY.
UCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAMES KAI
JACKSON WITH SINGLE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL TO FUND
THE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROMISE A WE
HAVE A STRONG RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE SAN DIEGO A COMMUNICABLE
EDGES DISTRICT AND WE ANTICIPATE
A ABOUT THREE THOUSAND SEND YOU
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
STUDENTS.
MOVING ON THIS YEAR TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND SUCCESSFULLY
EXITING THE PROGRAM AND WE JUST
WANTED TO OUR EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT OF THE.
THE STAFF'S COMMENTS THAT THIS
FUNDING OF COMMUNICABLE IS
PROMISES IS A CRITICAL STEP TO
INCREASING ACCESS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND DATA THIS IS THAT
AN ITEM THAT WE'RE GONNA.
FINALIZED LATER IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO HOLD THIS ISSUE A BUT
I JUST I WILL NOTE TO MISTER
OBERNOLTE. WHAT ONE OF THE?
?
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT LAST YEAR DURING THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND DURING THE
BILL CAME UP TO MR SANTIAGO.
ALWAYS. IS THAT HAVING IT
FOCUSED ON FULL TIME.
PARTICIPATION HAD A DRAMATIC
INCREASE AND IN SUCCESS OF
STUDENTS WHO GO PART TIME FORGET
THE NUMBER BUT THERE.
ACCESS RATE WAS I BELIEVE NO
LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
PERCENT SUITS TO GO FULL TIME.
WAS GONE NORTH OF OF A FIFTY
PERCENT I BELIEVE AND SO THE
THAT THE THOUGHTS HERE IS. HOW
PEOPLE COME IN?
AT THE GATE AND TO HAVE IT FREE
AND FULL TIME WILL PUT THEM ON A
BETTER.
PATH TO SUCCESS AN ADDITION TO
THAT STUDENT SUCCESS MEASURES
WHICH A PART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL. WITH HER
SO THANK YOU.
YES I ISSUE NUMBER THREE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
AT RIGHT SO TO KEY SO WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
PROPOSES A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION I'VE PROPOSITION AT
GENERAL FUND. AYE PROPOSITION
EIGHT EIGHT GENERAL FINANCE AS
SETTLE UP ONE TIME FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND INSTRUCTIONAL
EQUIPMENT FOR THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES. AND CONSISTENT WITH
PRIOR YEARS IN ADDITION TO
SCHEDULED MAINTENANCE COLLEGES
COULD USE THESE FUNDS FOR HAS
ARE HAZARDOUS STEPS AND THE BEAT
MEN ARCHITECTURAL BARRIER
REMOVAL PROJECTS WATER
CONSERVATION PROJECTS AND
LIBRARY MATERIALS I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU LA A. A GROUP BOTH THE
LA.
I WE RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
GOVERNOR'S UP PROPOSAL AND WE DO
THINK THAT THIS HELPS TO PAY
DOWN THE EXISTING BACKLOG OF
PROJECTS ARE COLLEGES AND ALSO
PROVIDES FOR A CHRISTIAN.
BY DEDICATING SOME OF THE
ONGOING PROBLEM THE EIGHT TO ONE
TYPE ACTIVITIES IF THERE IS A
DOWNTURN I'M IN IN THE COMING
YEAR. I'M WILL ALSO RECOMMEND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
REJECT SOME OF THE OTHER ONE
TIME PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET OR
WANT TO DEDICATE ADDITIONAL ONE
TIME FUNDING.
IF FROM EIGHTEEN NINETEEN PROP
NINETY EIGHT.
TO PROVIDE SUCH A CHRISTIAN WE
WOULD RECOMMEND ARE DOING SO
THROUGH THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ITEM.
CHRIS THANK YOU CAN MANY
COLLEGES WHICH LOST ONE OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
YOU KNOW I THINK WE. AGREE THAT
THIS ADDRESSES AN IDENTIFIED
NEED.
INTERESTS REPORT ARE AT OFFICE
ESTIMATED WORTH MORE THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS IN FACILITIES
MAINTENANCE NEEDS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS.
I JUST KNOW THAT YOUR AGENDA.
TALKS ABOUT HOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN ADDITION TO
USING THESE FUNDS FUND.
MAINTENANCE FROM GENERAL
PURPOSE RESOURCES LOCAL BOND
FUNDS AND OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND IN YOUR AGENDA NOTES THE ON
AND OFF FUNDING FOR THIS
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM SO I THINK
AS WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE FUNDING FORMULA AND RELATED
ISSUES WE SHOULD.
KEEP IN MIND WHAT KINDS OF
INCENTIVES WERE CREATING A ROUTE
MAINTENANCE ANOTHER BASIC HOUSE.
OKAY.
QUESTIONS.
YEAH PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE.
SEEING NONE EVERYONE LIKES
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND SEEMS
TO BE A GOOD USE OF. ONE TIME
PROP NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS
FOR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO STOP.
WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN AS
WELL.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR INNOVATION
AWARDS.
AND RIGHT SILKY SO THAT A
PRIVATE FINANCE AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE INNOVATION
AWARDS TO COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND
THESE INNOVATION AWARDS PUT. A
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
INNOVATIONS ARE REDUCE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS FOR STUDENTS
FROM TRADITIONALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS AS WELL
AS REGIONAL ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
CONSISTENT WITH THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS.
SO AS I'VE ADDED BY CHANCE ROSS
MANYA.
AB DESCRIBE THAT LAST JULY AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ADOPTED
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS AT THE
VISION A CALLS FOR THE SYSTEM TO
INCREASE COMPLETION AND TRANSFER
RATES TO REDUCE. THE NUMBER OF
AXIS UNITS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CAREER TECHNICAL
STUDENTS TO BECOME EMPLOYED IN
THEIR PHILLIP STUDY AND REDUCE
EQUITY GAPS AND REGIONAL GAPS
ACROSS ALL OF THESE MEASURES.
THE PROPOSED INNOVATION AWARDS
PROGRAM IS CRAFTED IN THE WAY TO
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
INNOVATIONS THAT REDUCE EQUITY
AND REGIONAL GAPS FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
INCLUDING LOW INCOME STUDENTS
STUDENTS WERE CURRENT AND FORMER
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITY DISABILITIES
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS FOR VETERANS I'LL OVER
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF EXISTING EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES AT THE GOAL OF
THIS PROGRAM IS FOR PROVIDE
COLLEGES.
UP FUNDS TO IMPLEMENT
INNOVATIONS THAT THEY WOULD NOT
HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN ABLE TO TEST
AND IMPLEMENT. THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WOULD ADMINISTER THAT
THESE AWARDS AND THE CHANCE OR
ON THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS WOULD
I MAKE THE AWARDS AND. I ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE IS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE TRAILER BILL
ABOUT GENERALLY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WOULD REPORT ON THE
ACTIVITIES SUPPORTED BY THE
FUNDS. AND THEY GENERATE FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WOULD REPORT
A SUMMARY OF THE OUTCOMES OF THE
STUDENT POPULATION AND THE
MEASURES THAT WERE USED TO. OUT
QUANTIFY THE REDUCTION OR
ELIMINATION OF ACHIEVEMENT IN
EQUITY GAPS.
I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU ALEJO.
YES WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL I THINK I'M MORE
CONCERNED IS THAT IT PROVIDES
LARGE SUMS OF.
A MONEY TO A SMALL NUMBER OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WITHOUT
REALLY A MECHANISM FOR IF THERE
ARE INNOVATIONS FOR
DISSEMINATING THEM ACROSS THE
STATE. I'M THE COLLEGES ARE IDEA
BOMBING A NUMBER OF INITIATIVES
MANY OF THESE ARE ALSO INTENDED
TO TO.
.
AT REDUCE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS SO WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE PROPOSAL
AND IF YOU DO WANT TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR ONE TIME PURPOSES
WITH THE RECOMMENDS OF FUNDING
ARE. INCREASING THE DEFERMENT
THAT.
THANK YOU PROFESSOR.
ALL PROVIDE BOTH AN OVERVIEW OF
OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AWARDS
AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND THEN
SOME POTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I'M SO IS YOUR AGENDA
NOTES AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BUDGET APPROPRIATED TWENTY
MILLION TO THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FOR THESE AWARDS. OF
THIS YEAR OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
SCALING INNOVATION ALSO THE
AWARDS ARE DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
BREAKTHROUGH INNOVATIONS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE DISTRICTS
THAT IMPROVE STUDENT SUCCESS.
DEMONSTRATE REVOLUTIONARY
LEARNING YOUR STUDENT SUPPORT
MODELS ARE SO STABLE AND CAN BE
SCALED REGIONALLY OR THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE EXPECT OF THE
AWARDS WILL BE BETWEEN ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AND FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THEY'RE INTENDED TO
HELP RECIPIENTS SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SELECTED
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE. THE
APPLICATION DEADLINE IS MONDAY
WE RECEIVED SIXTY FIVE
APPLICATIONS AND OUR OFFICE
INTENDS TO BEGIN REVIEWING THEM
SHORTLY. AND THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS WILL ANNOUNCE THE
WINNERS OF THE MAY MEETING.
MOVING OUT OF THE.
CURRENT PROPOSAL.
YOU KNOW AS WE'VE DISCUSSED THE
GOVERNOR BOARD OF GOVERNORS
ADOPTS THE BUDGET EACH FALL. AND
THIS PROPOSAL WASN'T INCLUDED IN
OUR BUDGET WE THINK THOUGH THAT
IT SENSIBLE AND SUPPORTS THE
GOALS INCLUDED IN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS.
OF ALSO SAY THAT WE THINK IT'S
RES THAT'S A REASONABLE WAY TO
SUPPORT CAPACITY BUILDING IN THE
SYSTEM ESPECIALLY AS WE DISCUSS
ANY FUNDING FORMULA. LAST WEEK
WE CONVENED A MEETING OF.
US OF RESEARCHERS TO TALK ABOUT.
ISSUES RELATED TO THE FUNDING
FORMULA AND ONE OF THE MAIN
POINTS OF THE RESEARCHERS MADE
WAS THAT SUCCESS OF FUNDING
FORMULA CHANGES. ARE TYPICALLY
RELATED TO THE CAPACITY OF
COLLEGES TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
MAKE THOSE CHANGES AND SO WE
THINK THE INNOVATION WORDS CAN
HELP TO BUILD THAT CAPACITY.
OKAY.
THANK YOU. I LET ME START OUT
WITH A QUESTION FOR FROM LA SO
THAT I I HEARD YOUR
RECOMMENDATION TO. TO OPPOSE
THIS AND REDIRECTED TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND.
AND THAT YOU GET THE SAME
RECOGNITION YOU HAD A YEARS BACK
AND I THINK NOW IS STILL BE
DIFFERENT IS.
IF YEARS AGO OVERTURE WHAT THEY
WOULD DO NOW THEY'VE DONE IT AND
WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO.
THE THE DESCRIPTION FROM THE
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
BREAKTHROUGH PROJECTS
REVOLUTIONARY PROJECTS.
HAVE WE HAVE WE SEEN ANY OTHER
ONES IN LAST YEAR'S THAT THAT
THAT MEET UP WITH THAT. THOSE
LOFTY GOALS
WE HAVE AND THE LIVING YET I
THINK THERE PUT THE FOR THE
FIRST RIGHT MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THE FIRST ROUND OF INNOVATION
AWARDS WERE REALLY ABOUT. BROUGH
WORDING.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES THAT
WERE ALREADY AND. HAD ALREADY
ADOPTED INNOVATIVE PRACTICES SO
THAT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WE
THOUGHT. WE CHANGE I THINK THAT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
FINANCES IN THE MYTH OF
COMPILING I'M INFORMATION FROM
THE THE FIRST ROUND OF. A
BECAUSE THAT RECEIVED THE
INNOVATION AWARDS.
WHERE WHERE THEY WERE GOING TO
THAT IMPLEMENT SOMETHING NEW SO
WE HAVE AN SEEN ANYTHING QUITE
YET THAT GIVES US A SENSE OF?
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE WORDS
I AM WHAT THE OUTCOMES BEEN AND
WHETHER OR NOT ANY OF THAT HAS
HAS KIND OF? BEEN DISSEMINATED
ACROSS THE STATE.
OKAY AND THEN FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THIS WASN'T IN THE
COMMUNICATIVE BUDGET REQUEST.
WHAT WAS THE REASON THAT THAT?
IF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SITE
THIS WITH.
WHERE THE END OF INCLUSION IN
THE BUDGET?
SO THAT WE THE WAY WE'VE AFTER
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
THAT THIS PROPOSAL ALIGNS WITH
THE GOALS OF THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS. AND WE CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT INNOVATION IS
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS.
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS FOR INSTANCE
WE SEE A LOT OF INNOVATIONS THAT
STAR AT.
COLLEGE LEVEL AT THINGS LIKE
THE COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM
MULTIPLE MEASURES AND THEN I
HAVE HAD THE POTENTIAL BEING
SCALED.
ACROSS.
AT THE SYSTEM AND WE OFTEN HEAR
THAT IT'S DIFFICULT TO INNOVATE
AND TO TEST NEW IDEAS AT THE
COLLEGE LEVEL SO THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT BRINGS TOGETHER
STAFF FACULTY. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO.
RECEIVE A GRANT TO IMPLEMENT
SOMETHING NEW SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TO ADDRESS.
VERY SIGNIFICANT ISSUES LIKE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP SO WE REALLY SAW
THIS ALIGNED.
OUT WITH THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
IN THOSE SCHOOLS AND THAT GOOD
USE OF ONE TIME FUNDING.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEE.
ARTS ITCHING.
I SEE THAT.
THIS STAFF REPORT INDICATES
THAT THERE WAS WITH TO BE A.
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
ON THE.
INTENDED TO SHOW THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE FIRST ROUND
OF INNOVATION AWARDS.
YES THERE WERE IN THE PROCESS
OF.
COLLECTING THAT INFORMATION IN
OUR OFFICES.
WILL WILL PROPRIETY THAT
INFORMATION THIS YEAR.
OKAY SEEING NO OTHER. QUESTIONS
WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN AS
WELL.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE STAFFING.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING MCCARTY
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MOLLY
BECAUSE OF WORK WITH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO MILLION ONGOING NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING CAPACITY AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. TO SUPPORT
RECENT INITIATIVES AND
INVESTMENTS THE STATE HAS MADE
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OUR STAFF REVIEWED RECENTLY
ENACTED LEGISLATIVE INITIATIVES
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TO
IDENTIFY WORKLOAD THAT WOULD
FURTHER SUPPORT THE CHANCELLOR'S
EFFORTS
TO PROVIDE GREATER LEADERSHIP
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND IMPROVE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
BASED ON OUR ANALYSIS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING NEW
RESOURCES TO BUILD STAFFING
CAPACITY TO HELP ACHIEVE THE
GOALS AND PRIORITIES OUTLINED IN
THE CHANCELLOR'S MISSION FOR
SUCCESS.
THESE FUNDED POSITIONS WOULD
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING SEVEN
PROGRAM AREAS.
ONE POSITION TO COORDINATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROPOSED
NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
THIS INDIVIDUAL WOULD BE TASKED
WITH WRITING THE REGULATIONS
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO COLLEGES TO HELP THEM
TRANSITION TO THE NEW FORMULA.
MONITORING THEIR PROGRESS AND
WORKING WITH COLLEGES WHO ARE
NOT ACHIEVING STUDENT OUTCOMES.
THAT THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA
REWARDS.
SIX POSITIONS INCLUDING ONE
ADMINISTRATOR TO DEVELOP AND
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROPOSED ONLINE COLLEGE.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WILL SEE
CONSIDERABLE NEW WORKLOAD AND
HELPING THE ONLINE COLLEGE GET
UP AND RUNNING.
INITIALLY THE ONLINE COLLEGE
WILL HAVE NO STAFF AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WILL BE
TASKED
WITH DEVELOPING THE GUIDING
PRACTICES AND PRINCIPLES.
WRITING THE NEW REGULATIONS
HOPING WITH THE ACCREDITATION
PROCESS DOING OUTREACH AND
DETERMINING THE APPROPRIATE
CAREER PATHWAYS THAT THE ONLINE
COLLEGE WILL OFFER.
AS A ONLINE COLLEGE BECOMES
FULLY OPERATIONAL THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WILL HAVE A
CONTINUED ROLE IN REVIEWING DATA
TO EVALUATE THE SUCCESS OF THE
ONLINE COLLEGE. AND HELPING
DISSEMINATE THE BEST PRACTICES
AND POLICIES OF THE ONLINE
COLLEGE TO THE OTHER HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN COLLEGES TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
INSTITUTIONAL EFFECTIVENESS
PARTICIPATION INITIATIVE.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS CAN ONLY BE
USED TO PROVIDE LOCAL ASSISTANCE
AND THERE'S A CLEAR DISTINCTION
BETWEEN ACTIVITIES THAT CAN BE
FUNDED THROUGH PROP NINETY
EIGHT.
AND THE ADDITIONAL STATE
OPERATIONS WORK LOAD THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WHICH MUST BE SUPPORTED
BY NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
OUR PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING TO
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF STUDENT
SUPPORT SERVICES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BOMBING OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE AB NINETEEN
WHICH WE DISCUSSED EARLIER
TODAY.
THE ADDITIONAL STAFF WOULD
DEVELOP REGULATIONS ANDALLOW
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE GREATER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THE LOCAL COLLEGES.
AND DETERMINE THE ELIGIBILITY OF
COLLEGES TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM.
FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATION
REQUIRES COLLEGES TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE FEDERAL LOAN PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE GREATER FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS.
AND THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
SHOULD BE HELPING THEM ESTABLISH
SUCH A LOAN PROGRAM.
ONE POSITION TO SUPPORT COLLEGE
EFFORTS TO EFFECTIVELY USE
MULTIPLE MEASURES TO BETTER
ASSESS IN PLACE STUDENTS INTO
COURSES.
AS REQUIRED IN AB SEVEN OH FIVE
WHICH WAS RECENTLY ENACTED.
THIS PERSON WOULD DEVELOP
REGULATIONS PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP COLLEGES
IMPLEMENT THE NEW MULTIPLE
MEASURES.
ASSESSMENT AND PLACEMENT
PROCEDURES.
ONE ADMINISTRATOR IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WORKFORCE AN
ECONOMIC DIVISION TO COORDINATE
AND SUPPORT THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE CT  COMPONENT OF THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
TWO POSITIONS TO CONTINUE WORK
ON THE GUIDED PATHWAYS
IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS INITIATIVE WAS INITIALLY
FUNDED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT AND FUNDING
WAS PROVIDED FOR ONE
ADMINISTRATOR AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
TO COORDINATE GUIDED PATHWAYS
ACTIVITIES HOWEVER THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE NEEDS
ADDITIONAL STAFFING TO SUPPORT
THE EFFORTS OF LOCAL COLLEGES AS
THE EMPLOYMENT GUIDED PATHWAYS
THAT THEIR CAMPUSES.
ONE POSITION EACH IN THE
ACCOUNTING AND HUMAN RESOURCES
DIVISIONS OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY OF THESE
UNITS WHICH ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERSTAFFED RESULTING IN DELAYS
IN PROCESSING CONTRACTS
SUBMITTING REIMBURSEMENT CLAIMS
AND HIRING NEW STAFF.
THE TWO MILLION WOULD ALLOW THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO FILL
FIFTEEN AUTHORIZED BUT VACANT
POSITIONS WHICH BE WOULD BE
RECLASSIFIED. AND REDIRECTED TO
MEET THE PROPOSED STAFFING NEEDS
WE'VE DESCRIBED.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS
EXISTING POSITION AUTHORITY FOR
THESE POSITIONS BUT NEEDS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO HIRE THE STAFF WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED. AS CRITICAL IN
HELPING THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
SUPPORT LOCAL COLLEGES EFFORTS
TO HELP STUDENTS SUCCEED.
THANK YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
HOWEVER BOTH LA OR WE HAVE COULD
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
THIS. I'M SO WE KIND OF BROKE
OUT THESE THE REQUEST IN TERMS
OF THREE THREE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES ONE THIS FUNDING FOR.
SERVE EXISTING WORKLOAD TIGHTER
INITIATIVES ARE THE ADOPTED.
SECOND ONE IS ONLINE COLLEGE IN
THE THIRD IS THE FUNDING FOR THE
FUNDING FORMULA AND THE CITY E.
K. TWELVE CITY.
SO ON THE FIRST PIECE FOR
FUNDING FOR EXISTING ABOUT WORK
WHAT WE WOULD WRECK RECOMMEND
REJECTS AND.
WE WE DIDN'T GET A LOT OF WORK
WITH THE TALENT THAT JUST BY THE
ONGOING WORK WOULD NEED.
AT THE CHANCES OF US AND WE ARE
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE WAS
A REVIEW LAST SPRING AND THAT
THAT THERE WERE SOME POSITIONS
INCREASED.
LAST MAY WHAT WE DO KNOW THAT
THE TOUGHEST OPPOSITE INDICATED
THAT THEY ARE LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT THEY MIGHT.
RESTRUCTURE THE THOUGH
ORGANIZATION TO FURTHER I'M
SUPPORT.
BECAUSE DISTRICTS AND IF IF
THERE IS A MORE DEDUCTIBLES IN
THE FUTURE WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER IT.
IN TERMS OF THE ONLINE COLLEGE
WE WOULD RECOMMEND. WILL NOT
PROVIDING ANY STATE OPERATIONS
FUNDING RELATED TO ONLINE
COLLEGE.
A LOT OF THE ACTIVITIES ARE UP
TO THOUGHTS ARE MORE THE TYPE OF
ACTIVE ACTIVITIES AT A COLLEGE
WOULD BE. UNDERTAKING THESE ARE
NOT OUR OVERSIGHT ROLE OF THE.
OF THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SO IF
THERE IS ANY NEED TO.
FOR THAT WORK WHEN WE THINK
THAT SHOULD BE FUNDED WITH THE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO THE
COLLEGE SO IF THERE IS CHAPTERS
OFFICE STAFF HAVE TO DO WE WOULD
RECKON THERE'D BE A
REIMBURSEMENT.
SOME KIND OF A REIMBURSEMENT
MODEL I USE FOR THAT PURPOSE.
WEIGHT WITH WITH REGARDS TO THE
KEY TO ALL OF A.
THE E. PROGRAM POSITION IN THE
FUNDING FORMULA WE REDUCE BEHOLD
RECOMMENDATION AND THOUGHT THAT
THE NEED FOR THOSE POSITIONS
WILL REALLY DEPEND.
SIGNIFICANTLY ON ULTIMATELY
WHAT.
WHAT PROPOSALS YOU ADOPT
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE FUNDING
FORMULA IF YOU HAVE A VERY
COMPLICATED MORE COMPLICATED?
APPROACH YOU MIGHT BE MORE
STUFF THAN JUST ONE UMBER
ALTERNATIVELY IF YOU ARE ARE
ADOPTING A NEW.
FUNNY FOR ME BUT ALSO
CONSOLIDATING CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS IN ELIMINATES MOST
REQUIREMENTS YOU MIGHT. BE ABLE
TO REDIRECT EXISTING POSITIONS
ALL ULTIMATELY HOW MANY YOU NEED
WILL DEPEND ON THE ULTIMATE
POLICIES ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU CHRISTMAS WHEN YOU
KNOW THE CHANCES OFFICE WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
WE THINK IT REFLECTS THE GROWING
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. PART OF
THOSE ARE CHANGES MADE BY THE
GOVERNOR OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
PART OF THOSE ARE CHANGES IN THE
APPROACH BY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AND CHANCELLOR OAKLEY.
ALL KNOW TO FUNDAMENTAL SHIFTS
THAT CHANGE OUR THINKING ABOUT
THE ROLE OF THE STATE OFFICE THE
FIRST AS I MENTIONED IS THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS. WE'VE TALKED
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ITS GOALS BUT
IT ALSO HIGHLIGHTS COMMITMENTS
THAT OUR OFFICE IS MADE. AND AND
ONE BIG SHIFT IS A MORE ACTIVE
ROLE FOR OUR OFFICE NOT WITH
REGARD TO COMPLIANCE.
WOULD STATE RULES AND STATE
LAWS BUT ON LEADERSHIP
SUPPORTING CAPACITY BUILDING
DIVISIONS.
SAYS IN PART THAT OUR OFFICE
WILL FOSTER YOU'D BE USE OF DATA
IN KOREAN EVIDENCE TAKE
OWNERSHIP OF GOALS AND
PERFORMANCE ENABLE ACTION AND
THOUGHTFUL INNOVATION AND LEAD
THE WORK OF PARKING YOUR CAR
CROSS SYSTEMS.
THE SECOND SHIFT AGAIN IS
SOMETHING WE'VE MENTIONED.
AND THAT'S THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE GUIDED PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK
WHICH YOU SUPPORTED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR'S BUDGET. WELL THAT
WORK IS BEING DONE AT THE
COLLEGES ARE OFFICES ALSO TRYING
TO MODEL HOW WE TREAT CLEAR
PATHWAYS TO EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
ARE ONE EXAMPLE IS THAT WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO TEAR DOWN THE
FALSE DICHOTOMY BETWEEN ACADEMIC
AFFAIRS AND STUDENT SERVICES.
THROUGH THE CREATION OF A NEW
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION.
AND SO THAT WORK IS ONGOING IT
MAY ALTER.
HOW WE WOULD ALLOCATE THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CHANCELLOR
OAKLEY HAS BEEN IN ISRAEL FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR BUT MANY OF US
ON THE TEAM INCLUDING ME?
ARE EVEN THEY WERE AND WERE
BEGINNING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW WE SHOULD THE LINE ALL OF
OUR RESOURCES INCLUDING OUR
EXISTING RESOURCES BUT ALSO ANY
ADDED RESOURCES IN THE BUDGET.
TO MEET THE VISION GOALS BOB AS
WE GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS WE'RE
HAPPY TO REPORT TO YOU.
OUR PROGRESS TO YOU ALL AND I
THINK WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
THE LA DOES POINT THAT.
YOU KNOW AT THIS POINT WE DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC.
.
WORKLOAD JUSTIFICATIONS ON A
POSITION BASIS I THINK WE CAN.
YOU KNOW.
TALK TO YOU ABOUT HOW WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT BENCHMARKING
AGAINST OTHER ORGANIZATIONS BUT
YOU KNOW WE THINK THE NEED IS
THERE AND WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
I'M JUST FIVE ACT YOU OVER THE
COMING MONTHS.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ESTIMATES RICHIE.
SO.
IN TERMS OF THE.
K. THROUGH TWELVE.
CORD TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM
I I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET THE IN MY
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS WITH
THE FULL.
SUPPORT OF THE THE CHANCELLOR.
I THINK WE WOULD DEFER TO YOU ON
THAT DECISION IT'S A ROLE THAT
WE HAVEN'T HISTORICALLY PLAYED
WE ARE.
WERE HAPPY TO PLAY WHATEVER
ROLE THAT.
YOU ALL DECIDE I THINK WE AGREE
ON THAT.
THE PROBLEM STATEMENT AROUND
COORDINATION OF K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAMS
AROUND REGIONAL WORKFORCE NEEDS
HOW YOU STRUCTURE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION.
MAINLY WE HAVE I BELIEVE OVER
NINE HUNDRED SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
YEAH I OKAY AB NINE HUNDRED TO A
THOUSAND.
.
AND.
IT IT DOESN'T SEEM REALISTIC
THAT WE WOULD HAVE WANTED
MINUTES STRAIGHTER.
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
COORDINATE THESE REGIONAL
CT  WORK FORCES OR WHERE
PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT DOES THE CHANCES OFFICE
HAVE OPINION ON THAT.
ALL I CAN DEFERRED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE.
RATIONALE I WOULD SAY THAT.
TO THE EXTENT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE IS CHARGED WITH.
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM I
THINK WE WOULD. BELIEVE THAT
THERE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
NEEDED IN ANY CASE I THINK WE
WOULD RELY HEAVILY ON OUR PART
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS OF THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. BUT.
BUT IF THAT IS A ROLE THAT THAT
YOU ALL CHARGES WITH BUT I THINK
WE NEED.
WILL NEED RESOURCES TO DO THAT.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE YOU'RE
REALLY FIGHT A FIGHT HAD TO NEW
ROLE THERE.
I THINK WE RESPECT THE FACT THAT
THESE ARE FOLKS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION.
WORKS WITH WORKED WITH REGULAR.
I THINK THIS IS YOU BRING UP A
GOOD POINT MISTER MURATSUCHI
THAT A FEW OF THESE ARE
DEPENDENT ON OUR OTHER ACTIONS
THE ONLINE.
DEBATE WHICH. IS A BIG DEBATE AS
YOU SAW YESTERDAY.
AND AND THEN THE FUNDING FORMULA
WHICH WILL GET TO AND THEN THAT
THE CT PROPOSAL AND SO I THINK
ALIVE THESE. ARE PREMATURE WE WE
WE WHAT WE ONE ACT NOW ANYWAY
HOLD US OPEN BUT. THAT LOOKS
LIKE ABOUT HALF OF THESE
ARE PREDICATED BY WHAT WE DO
WITH THE OTHER ITEMS.
BUT I WILL NOTE THAT THAT THAT
YOU KNOW ONE THE REASONS THAT WE
LIKE.
THE EXISTING STRUCTURE OF THE
THINKING PROGRAM GOING THROUGH
CD SO NOW. WE HAVE SOME
IT'S HARD TO THAT AS WELL.
MISTER MARK MISTER BELL PAL. YES
ARM.
I'M THE NEW GUY ON THE
COMMITTEES GO UP STILL TRYING TO
CONNECT ALL THE DOTS.
THE TWELVE IT'S THE FIFTEEN
POSITIONS THEY WERE FUNDED AT
ONE TIME WORK THEY.
ALL TAKE A STAB AT THE SO I
THINK.
.
YES THE ANSWER IS.
YOU OF THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR CONTROL AGENCIES BUDGET
INCLUDING OUR AGENCIES TO ISSUE
CONTROLLED ON A DOLLAR BASIS IN
YOU.
ALSO CONTROLLED ON A POSITION
BASIS
OVER TIME.
AGENCY BUDGETS INCLUDING OURS.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
NUMBER OF POSITIONS THAT WERE
FUNDED AND THE NUMBER AND WHERE
THE DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT.
BECOMES A LITTLE MORE
DISJOINTED SO WE HAVE A POSITION
WE HAVE A SITUATION NOW WHERE WE
HAVE AUTHORITY TO HIRE.
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO FILL
THOSE POSITIONS BECAUSE OF YOU
KNOW ALONG. A SET OF INCREMENTAL
WAYS IN WHICH.
THOSE TWO NUMBERS HAVE BECOME
MORE DISTORTED OKAY BECAUSE.
I SUPPORT THESE FIFTEEN
POSITIONS.
.
DRAWING ON PAST EXPERIENCE IN
GOVERNMENT.
WE WOULD OFTEN USE VACANT
POSITIONS TO TRANSFER THAT MONEY
TO OTHER USES
SO IS THAT WHAT HAPPENED HERE
IT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT'S HAPPENED
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME AND
OVERSIGHT OF JUST INCREMENTAL
DECISIONS OKAY AND AND I'M NOT
CRITICIZING AT ALL BECAUSE IT'S
A NORMAL PRACTICE IN. ANY
ORGANIZATION SO JUST SO YOU KNOW
I WOULD SUPPORT THE EXCERPTED
ADDITIONS ESPECIALLY DEPENDING
UPON THE DIRECTION WE GO ON THE
ONLINE COLLEGE BECAUSE IF IT'S
GOING TO BE A TOUGH ISSUE.
AND YOU NEED SUPPORT SO.
THIS WEEK THANK YOU FRED SIR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WILL NOTE
THAT RELATIVE LEE NIMBLE TWO
MILLION STUDENTS LASTED TWO
HUNDRED POSITIONS.
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE.
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
ABOUT A THOUSAND POSITIONS.
NO COMMENT I'M SURE THEIR SWISS.
YES
BUT THAT KNOW IT'S APPLES AND
ORANGES BUTI KNOW THAT.
AT THAT TIME.
VERY EFFICIENT AT RQ LA CALLED
SYSTEM QUESTIONS.
OKAY THIS ISSUE AGAIN WILL BE.
HELD OPEN LAST ISSUE WE WANTED
TO.
JUST CIRCLE BACK ON THAT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT IN THE
MONIES WE.
WE ARE AND PUT THE BUDGET
RELATED TO VETERANS RESOURCE
CENTERS.
THANK YOU ALL MY COLLEAGUES.
WALKING UP ARTISTS MAKE SOME
INTRODUCTORY COLUMN COMMENTS WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
ACTION WITH REGARD FOR VETERANS
STUDENTS.
YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT BEYOND VETERAN RESOURCE
CENTERS.
WE'RE WORKING TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF VETERANS ACROSS
ORGANIZATION. THAT WERE SPENDING
TIME CONSIDERING HOW WE
RECOGNIZE THE KNOWLEDGE SKILLS
AND ASSETS THAT VETERANS BRING
TO OUR INSTITUTIONS AND AS
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY MENTIONED
YESTERDAY OUR OFFICES.
THINKING ESPECIALLY HARD AYE
ABOUT COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION
WHICH WE THINK CAN HAVE AN
IMPORTANT PACKED FOR VETERANS
GIVEN.
THE SKILLS THEY'VE LEARNED.
WHILE SERVING SOUL INTRODUCED
DAVID LAWRENCE WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR VETERANS SERVICES IN OUR
OFFICE AND HOPE PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE USE OF FUNDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PARTY
MEMBERS COMMITTEE APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE TWO FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR APPROPRIATIONS THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET. IN
SUPPORT OF THE CREATION OF NEW
OR AUGMENTATION OF EXISTING
BETTER RESOURCE CENTERS.
AS YOU KNOW ONE WAS IN ONGOING
FUNDING IN THE OTHER IS A ONE
TIME COMPETITIVE GRANT FUNDING.
SO ALL START WITH THE ONGOING
FUNDING THE.
THE BUDGET LANGUAGE AROUND THE
ONGOING FUNDED REQUIRED OUR
OFFICE TO COME UP WITH THE
MINIMUM SAYS STANDARDS FOR HIGH
FUNCTIONING BETTER RESOURCE
CENTER.
SO WE TURN TO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE VETERANS SERVICES
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHICH IS MADE
UP OF INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE
STATE OF THE LOCAL LEVEL. WHO
REALLY?
ARE LEADING OUR SYSTEM WITH
REGARDS TO DEVELOPING BETTER
RESOURCE CENTERS PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR VETERANS ON CAMPUS.
AND THAT GROUP.
GOT TOGETHER AND CAME UP WITH
THIS MINIMUM SAYS STANDARDS
WHICH WE RELEASED TO THE SYSTEM.
I'M NOT ONLY DO THEY MEAN DID
THEY COME UP WITH THE MINIMUM
SAYS STANDARDS THEY ALSO CAME UP
OF THE FUNDING FORMULA FOR.
DISTRIBUTING THEIR ALLOCATING
THAT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDS.
SO.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE FUNDING
COLLEGES WERE REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE A CERTIFICATION FORM
THAT INCLUDED THOSE MINIMUM SET
THE STANDARDS AND IDENTIFY WHAT
STANDARDS THEY CURRENTLY MEET.
AND THE THINKING BEHIND THAT WAS
THAT IT SHOULD THIS FUNDING
CONTINUE WE CAN ASK THEM TO DO
THAT FROM YOUR YEAR IN THE
COMPARATIVE. YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE TO PRIOR TO.
ENSURE PROGRESS IS BEING MADE
TOWARDS MEETING THOSE STANDARDS.
SO WITH REGARDS TO THE FUNDING
FORMULA IT WAS FAIRLY SIMPLE THE
FIRST YEAR WHEN I TOOK THIS
POSITION OVER KNOCKED OVER THE
GOAL WAS TO GET THE FUNDING OUT
BE THE STATE DEPARTMENT SYSTEM
ANNEX OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT WAS
IN JANUARY. SO WE QUICKLY CAME
UP WITH THAT OF VERY BASIC
FORMULA. THE FOR
TWENTY PERCENT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WAS DIVIDED EVENLY AMONGST EACH
COLLEGE AT SOME IS CERTIFICATION
FORM REQUESTING FUNDING.
THE REMAINING FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED BASED ON.
EACH COLLEGES PRO RATED SHARE OF
THE TOTAL NUMBER STUDENT
VETERANS CERTIFIED BY EVERY
COLLEGE THAT SIMILAR
CERTIFICATION FORM DURING THE
STATE FISCAL YEAR SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN.
SO THE BASS LIKE OPPONENT WAS
THERE TO PROTECT SMALL COLLEGES
THAT DON'T SERVE ARE A TON OF
VETERANS. AND AND SOME OF THE
RESULTS OF THAT ALLOCATION
BECAUSE THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN HAVE
GONE OUT THEY WENT OUT AS I SAID
IN.
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR THE
SMALLEST ALLOCATION WAS IN ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE DOLLARS AND WHAT PALAVA DAY.
PALO VERDE SERVED.
CERTIFIED EIGHT VETERANS DURING
THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN FISCAL
YEAR SEE MY SAY TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS NOT A LOT OF PETER
LAB OR RELEASED BY.
HERE ELEVEN ABOUT A RESOURCE.
THE LARGEST ALLOCATION WHAT
PALOMAR COLLEGE PALOMAR
CERTIFIED OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED
VETERANS IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
AND THEY RECEIVED A HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
WHICH WAS.
YOU KNOW I HEALTHY ALLOCATION.
WITH HER GARCIA ONE TIME
FUNDING.
WE'RE IN THE FINAL STAGES OF
COMPLETING THE REQUEST FOR
APPLICATION FOR THOSE FUNDS. AND
ANTICIPATE RELEASING THAT BY THE
END OF MARCH.
AND HAVE MEANING GONE THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF COLLECTING
APPLICATIONS REVIEWED THE SCORE
THE APPLICATIONS AND ANNOUNCE
THE THE SUCCESSFUL APPLICANTS.
I BY THE END OF MAY SO THAT IS
THE GOAL WITH REGARDS THE.
THE THE GRANT FUNDING AT THIS
TIME.
OVER ALL THE DO YOU VIEW THAT
THERE IS THERE IS THAT THERE'SA
NEED OUT THERE IBC SEVENTY
THOUSAND.
VETERANS AND OUR COMMUNICATIVE
AS A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER AND THAT
I THINK THAT. MORE HELP AND MORE
THE MERRIER SO. IF THERE WAS A
DESIRE.
WHAT KID BUT CAN BE DONE?
OFFICIALLY.
IN IN THE IN THIS CONTEST FEEL.
I ABSOLUTELY THERE'S.
I NEED TO ACTUALLY JUST
RECENTLY CAN TARGET OF OUR
SYSTEM AND OUR NUMBERS OF
ACTUALLY SWORN EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND STE IN BETTER AND SO.
AS YOU SEE IT'S CLIMBING.
NINETY FIVE OR NINETY SEVEN OF
OUR COLLEGES ACTUALLY HAVE
BETTER RESOURCE CENTERS BUT THE
ISSUE IS.
SISTERS BEEN A FUNNY PART THIS
YEAR THE THERE WILDLY
INCONSISTENT IN SIZE AND IN
STOPPING AND SERVICES OFFERED.
SO I THINK.
I THINK THE ONGOING FUNDING IS
IS PROBABLY THE MOST EFFICIENT
VEHICLE FAR OFFICE TO GET THE
FUNDS OUT SO IF THERE WERE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
GRANT FUNDING IS IS IS ALWAYS
GREAT BUT IT'S A VERY LABOR
INTENSIVE PROCESS TO CREATE THE
RFA AND THEN I GET THE PEOPLE
YOU NEED TO TO SCORE THOSE AND
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GIVE HIM AS
MUCH MONEY OUT TO AS MANY PEOPLE
SO. I THINK.
FROM MY STANDPOINT I WOULD
SUGGEST THE ONGOING FUNDING
VERSUS GRANT FUNDING SO
EVERYBODY GETS A LITTLE BIT OF
PIECE OF THE PIE I THINK THAT
WOULD. NOT BE THE BEST BUS ROUTE
MY OPINION NOW IS THE FOR IS WE
AYE WE WANTED AND TOWARD A
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THE FEW MONTHS
AGO WHEN UP IN ROCKLIN WHAT'S
AGAINST TERRORISTS HERE EXACTLY.
AND WE WE WENT AND VISITED THAT
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER.
AND IT WAS THE FIRST THE OVER
THE YEARS I TALKED ABOUT THE
FACILITY THAT THEY CAN THAT THEY
CREATED THERE AND THEN COURSES
STAFFING.
SO SOME OF THESE.
HUNDRED FIFTEEN OR SO COLLEGES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT MAYBE
DON'T HAVE IS IS IT REALLY NEED
RESOURCES TAKE GREAT IT IS THAT
THEY NEED A.
SOLELY A PORTABLE BUILDING THERE
OR IS IT STAFFING THAT THEY CAN
HAVE A PLACE IN EXISTING.
COLLEGE CAMPUS WHY ETHNIC A
REALIST IT'S ALWAYS.
ITO THE TOUGH PART TO GET IS A
SPACE ON CAMPUS.
.
YOU KNOW THAT'S TOUGH I YOU KNOW
WITH NINETY SEVEN BECAUSE HAVING
AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S SOME LEVEL
OF SUCCESS HEARING GAINES SPACE
ON CAMPUS SO WERE WERE SHORT
EIGHTEEN COLLEGES THIS POINT IT
WORKS IF. SEVENTEENTH THAT ARE
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN ONLINE BUT.
SO I THINK JUST. FUNDING TO TO
YOU KNOW EXPAND THOSE SINNERS TO
YOU KNOW IT AS THE GROUP REALLY.
REVISE YOUR GROUP REALLY
RECOMMENDS HAVING SEPARATE
OFFICES WITHIN THE CENTER SO
THAT YOU CAN HAVE PRIVACY FOR
COUNSELING OR THE OR BENEFIT
CERTIFICATION. AND PROBABLY I
WOULD GUESS MANY OF THOSE DON'T
HAVE PRIVATE OFFICES SOME MORE
ADVANCED ONES DO BUT SO YOU KNOW
SOME. TEN PREVENT FOR LACK OF A
BETTER TERM WOULD WOULD WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL BUT THEN ALSO
STAFFING.
GROUP RECOMMENDED ONE FULL TIME
DIRECTOR LATIMER STAFFORD VA
WORK STUDY STUDENTS WHICH IS A
GREAT PROGRAM BECAUSE WE GET
STUDENT VETERANS PAID FOR DOING
WORK BUT.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A DECENT A
COUPLE ERA MAYBE WORKS STAY
STUDENT YOU NEED A DIRECTOR OF
SOME SORT OVER OVER THE.
OKAY COULD I I WOULD JUST ADD I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ALSO TO HAVE AS
PART OF THE FUNDING FORMULA
CONVERSATION IN THE
CONSOLIDATION OF CATEGORICAL
SPENT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT. WE THINK IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT YOU CREATE THE
RIGHTS RIGHT INCENTIVES AROUND
HOW TO SERVE THIS POPULATION OF
STUDENTS ANOTHER POPULATION OF
STUDENTS THAT WE THINK. YOU
KNOW.
REQUIRE NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
ABOUT.
YET SOME. I'M WEARING TWO HATS
ON THIS ONE BECAUSE I'M ALSO THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE VETERANS CAN.
SO
JUST IN A NUTSHELL LIKE THE
ELEVATOR SPEECH.
MANY OF THE VETERANS.
WENT INTO THE MILITARY RIGHT OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL.
SO THEIR LIFELINE LITERALLY
THEIR LIFELINE IS THAT WHEN THEY
GET OUT THERE FOUR YEARS MINIMUM
BEHIND EVERYBODY ELSE
OKAY PEOPLE ARE GRADUATING FROM
BERKELEY. WHILE A LOT OF THESE
KIDS ARE STARTIN TO GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SO THERE FOUR YEARS BEHIND RIGHT
OUT THE GATE.
AND THEY NEED TO GET A JOB. AND
THEY NEED TO GET IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THAT'S THE
MAIN THING.
WE HAVE A VETERAN SUICIDE RATE
OF TWENTY TWO. PER DAY IN THE
UNITED STATES
DON'T KNOW REALLY WHAT IT IS IN
CALIFORNIA.
DON'T HAVE THAT.
BUT ONCE YOU GET THE VETERANS ON
TRACK.
THEY ACTUALLY AND YOU YOU WOULD
HAVE THE NUMBERS MORE THAN I
WOULD.
THEY TEND TO STICK WITH. MANY OF
THEM ARE MARRIED AND THEIR
SPOUSES SENATE IN THE SCHOOL AND
WORK THEY'RE NOT.
GOOF OFF
SO THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
.
AND.
THE FLAT RATES I THINK ARE VERY
EFFECTIVE I'VE BEEN TO MANY OF
THE VETERANS CENTERS THEY'RE NOT
JUST TO ASSIST VETERANS IN THEIR
SCHOOLING.
OF MANY OF THEM HAVE PTSD MANY
OF.
ARE CAUGHT IN A TRAP LIKE
LITTLE RATS IN THE VA SYSTEM.
AND THEY GET TOGETHER AND
COMPARE NOTES AND THEY GET
EDUCATED IN ALL HOW TO ACCESS
ALL THEIR BENEFITS.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN INSTEAD OF
BEING TRAPPED LIKE A RAT.
THEY'RE WORKING TOGETHER AND
ACTUALLY GETTING SOME OF THEIR
BENEFITS AND GETTING SOME OF
THEIR APPEALS TAKING CARE OF. SO
THESE VETERAN SENATORS
ARE OFTEN FOR PEOPLE OF A LIFE
RING IT'S A LIFE RAFT FOR.
AND I THINK.
JUST MY OPINION OBSERVATION I
THINK THE TRACK WERE ON IS VERY
GOOD.
.
IF WE STAY AT THE FLAT RATES
THAT WAY. EACH COLLEGE EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAN A.
TAILOR THEIR PROGRAM.
TO THE VETERAN COMMUNITY BECAUSE
IN SAN DIEGO YOU HAVE NAVY
MARINES QUE THAT'S ONE CULTURE A
SUBCULTURE. OTHER AREAS WE HAVE
AIRFORCE WE HAVE ARMY WE HAVE
NATIONAL GUARD EXCEPT SO EACH
VETERAN CULTURE. CAN BE
DIFFERENT IN THAT AREA AND ALSO
THEY CHANGE EVEN IF IT'S SO.
MARINE NAVY CULTURE THEY MIGHT
BE DIFFERENT IN THE DIFFERENT
AREAS.
THAT'S JUST THE NATURE OF HUMAN
BEINGS
SO. I COMMEND YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
.
MORE FEEL MORE IS ALWAYS BETTER
RIGHT BUT.
NEXT YEAR.
I'M I'M KEENLY GOING TO LISTEN
ASSUMING ON HERE.
I AM KEENLY GOING TO LISTEN TO
WHAT YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE IF
WE NEED TO EXPAND IT. OR IF
YOU'RE OKAY WITH THE FUNDING WE
HAVE BECAUSE THESE VETERANS
CENTERS.
THEY'RE FRUGAL THEY DO A LOT
WITH VERY LITTLE THAT I GIVE
YOUR HOMEWORK ASSIGNMENT MISTER
VOEPEL. AGAIN HOW ABOUT I GIVE
YOU HOMEWORK ASSIGNMENT.
YOU HEARD WITH THAT SO I THINK
WE'RE OPEN TO POTENTIALLY.
LOOKING AT THIS IN THE MAY
REVISE AND MAYBE AUGMENTED SO
MAYBE IF YOU CAN.
HELP US COME UP WITH WHAT'S
NEEDED IS IT MORE STAFFING IS
ARE THE FACILITIES AND WHERE THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS ARE SO I JUST.
YEAH THROWING MONEY TO THROW
MONEY AROUND.
I'D BE GLAD TO AND AS YOU KNOW
I'M A FISCAL CONSERVATIVE IN
EVERY PENNY HAS TO COUNT
THANK YOU YES SIR OKAY.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL.
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN AS WELL.
AND.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
PARTICIPATION TODAY.
THANK YOU.
MILITARY
.
SOURCE.
FOR
.
PAGE